hey my name is May and I saw this trend
on tick tock did you know I liked you
know non selects enter this form from a
youtuber named jazzy and you ever liked
me
yes since its quarantine and honestly I
have nothing better to do I mean to do
it today so the layout of it is
surprising not I had a crush on you once
I may have hat or currently have a crush
on you
what's your name are you queer because
yes I am sending this to a couple of
straight girls Thanks
did you know that I like you if you know
how did you know did you like me back
would you've given me a chance if I made
a move any final words and then
assessment they're okay to be this video
and I also giving them an option put a
photo so maybe you guys can see what all
my questions look like and you can see
my type just kidding I actually don't
have a time wow I'm a lot more nervous
than I thought I was gonna be okay I'm
gonna go okay just do it right wow this
is scary okay we're done for the past
day I don't think I've never felt so
much anxiety and my life may be and I
didn't even think I was gonna like care
that much I was like huh this is not
funny game um until I started getting
texts and calls from these girls and I
haven't talked long are you query yes
did you know that I liked you had a
feeling you know we talked about it he
knew how did you know the suppressed
sexual attention back again hmm would
you have given me a chance made me to
move she said yes and all capitals my
junior
I mean my effectiveness and my
personality my date ability 10 okay come
on she said we'd show any final words
Tennyson would still hit honestly and I
have a boyfriend but like same Maya is
somebody that I talked to my freshman
year of high school she's honest I like
the first girl that like ghosted me
what's your name my re queerest
sometimes yeah that was kind of worried
did you know that I like you know when
acting surprised okay that was like
definitely a fake answer could be fully
like talk if you knew how do you know
she said I was convincing you took a
$300 over to my house oh my god I
literally Oh bird from Chicago to
Michigan to see this girl yes I did you
like me back she said I'm still in love
I don't know if it's bro series cover
like she literally could like be
actually in love with me and I would
think that she was making a joke so
would you have given me access if I made
a move wish you whatever okay I try
anyways ranked my attractiveness 10 rate
my personality 10 thank you right my
ability 10 what's your relationship now
you're one of my favorite people and I'm
sorry you met me well I'm not
and she's not my favorite once you wanna
say she's a great girl sometimes things
will work out snow you've been to be
friends of people that's fine
any final words I'm Tina India oh my
gosh so India
spoiler alert I sent her this and I hope
she answered is a girl that I'm like
currently next is Chelsea who we have
been literally talking on and on since
our junior year of high school like we
almost live in the same College
we always like talk for a second and
then stop talking and talk for a second
and stop talking like in between all of
our relationships
all right great yes do you know I like
you guess was so op that if you knew how
did you know we confess we confess our
love to each other every two months
ah painfully true that you like me back
yes we do give me a chance my man movie
yes bring my attractiveness 10 Raymond
personality 10 well honestly these girls
are putting - me up I feel like they
just don't like they have to say it
Billy I'll take repeatability ten what's
our relationship now she said may please
date me
Kamiya we've literally been saying this
since high school like I don't
wow it's just like making me so giddy
okay next Emma so this girl I also
talked to my freshman year of college
like actually right before I started
dating my last serious girlfriend what
you mean Emma are you queer very you
know I like you guess was so obvious
that if you knew how do you know you
literally came over to my dorm when you
were drunk might like I said drunk may
really have something to say did you
like me back yes would you have given me
a chance I'm in a movie she said he does
anyone we're kind of made out well yeah
meet my attractiveness no I'm
there's 98 yeah wonder what I lost two
points for maybe it was like the whole
ghost thing for absolutely no reason
but and ain't I'll take it meet my fate
ability for okay valid what's our
relationship now I asked advice about
moving to LA we're on toes close friends
list so I would say we're tight honestly
true that is the definition of
friendship at this point that was not
that I was actually nervous about her as
well because I was kind of a date card
Maggie okay Maggie is one of my
childhood friends she's one of the first
girls I had a crush on like growing up I
think I had a crush on her when I was
like 13 and like it was very before I
even like knew I was gay I knew I liked
her it was so but she's like one of my
best friend's I [ __ ] love her
are you query yes did you know that I
like to know I'm actually surprised did
you like me back and no damn my first no
would you give me a chance I made a move
yes the [ __ ] in my darkness ten baby
remembers now these times a ability
what's our relationship now each oh yeah
we're like literally best friends now
and you final word she said when we
doing this thing [ __ ] call me we can do
whatever you want Susan this was okay I
really found just going straight but I
have since found out that she's not but
she was in one of my classes my junior
year it's like last year and we hung out
like a couple of times she was like one
of my friends and filling and like
before I moved to LA so let's see you
said are you queer kind of hetero
flexible if you consider that a thing
mostly straight sometimes gay what an
explanation thank you for the
clarification dude did you know I liked
you had a feeling if you knew how do you
know when you rang figured to litter
Mutual's that you would tap oh my god I
made this thing of like Mutual's on
Twitter that I would hook up with and
she was she was on the last did you like
me baggy guys oh my god would you have
given me a chance I made it my own fella
are you kidding me Wow the most
opportunities they might Ryan is 10
right my personality
time rema date ability 9 why not attend
how Susan what's a little Asian dude no
cross country support buddies always
rooting for you from afar all meant
something any final words oh my god it's
just so nice she said I love you man and
I love your doing a beautiful social
media thing I'm so honored being good in
this I stay crunching on in mind you
from 3,000 miles away I gave you a ninth
date ability because you are 3,000 miles
away and long-distance little cheese
sucks compared to in real life you know
this and you know I love you and why the
line between like dating and friendship
and lesbian relationships is so
confusing like I don't know if I'm gonna
be you if I want to be with you and
Britt just like want to be her best
friend Jessica so jess is something that
I met on Twitter when I was little Ike
14 but I've always had like a little
cotton or except I do so funny are you
clear yes so you know that like you
didn't know he came known to be
oblivious only being crushed on unless
I'm told yeah definitely never expresses
her did you like me back
she said attracted to but never got the
chance to get to know you better very
valid would you have given me a chance
my maiden movie guys okay I'm gonna try
to miss have a good personality 10 read
my date ability 10 I love these girls
see I think nice girls they're all being
so nice to me I know these [ __ ] do
not all think that I'm a 10 I'm dated
but it would be like if I was a 10 you'd
be dating me but like go on what's our
lady did not which we have an out more
any final words laughing at myself for
not catching on that you've ever crushed
on me even though we've met on tinder
yeah that's what I'm saying husbands are
stupid but it's okay alright yeah this
is what I'm nervous funny cuz I guess
not like we're literally talking right
now like we actually I got kinda like
we're talking any been talking so like
I'm scared okay
hi queer hell yeah I am did you know
that I like to not so aw that first but
yes if you knew how do you know my heart
is beating so fast and we're gonna throw
up okay if you know how did you know
we'd stay up talking so the birds came
out almost every night sure we did
literally stay up till like 3:00 a.m.
every single
did you like me back I guess you could
say a little more than Mike would you
give me a chance I made the minnow is
that too bad I made the first move twice
what okay
and this is irrelevant but I need
everybody to know I made the first move
not Hearn you're gonna have a talk about
that I literally okay whatever ray my
TARDIS ten thank you personality time
date ability ten what's our relationship
now speaking of an unofficial DTR oh my
god yeah we have not teacher we can talk
about something you still haven't DTR it
so that's on being terrified of
commitment any final words I come she
said I kind of really want you to my
girlfriend so here's me wanting to
officially DT I thought I thought hi so
maybe we'll get an update on that oh my
god okay I don't know okay I'm gonna
call her mystery girl okay no one I was
really nervous about this girl honest
yeah ghosted pretty pretty severely so
I'm a little bit nervous about her so
that's a query yes
did you know what I like - I thought you
did then you did a 180
oh god it's already bad if you know how
did you know we literally talked every
night new photos me non-stop did you
like me back yes
would you have given me a chance I made
a new [ __ ] I didn't you pulled out okay
three nine track is this nine make my
personality five yeah it was a big rate
my great ability to also valid what's
our relationship now you've ghosted me
after three months of what I thought was
exclusive talking and then haven't
spoken to me and so you said this so
great no hard feelings okay she really
went in honestly I deserve it but like I
would she and that was the last one this
was honestly such a fun experience I
definitely was so nervous and honestly
like I still like I'm kind of like shake
you a little bit still cuz I that was
old Oh like I feel like I just like
woman's my old diary and like dug up all
these past feelings but to every girl
that I've ever had a crush on you're all
great and beautiful and there was a
reason I had a crush on you so maybe do
this maybe don't if you're sensitive but
if you're bored honestly you go for it
it was really fun so that's it
[Music]